-So happy to have you here.
-Great to be here, Seth.
-Absolutely delighted.
And I want to get
to your new film,
but can we talk about
"In Bruges" just a little bit?
-We certainly can.
I hear you kind of like it
a little bit.
-I´m a little weird about
"In Bruges." I´m so --
I talk about "In Bruges" so much
that people have gifted me
"In Bruges" posters.
That´s right outside my office.
So that --
I see your name everyday.
-I´ve never seen that poster.
-You´ve never seen that poster?
No, that was --
It was a knockoff poster.
You didn´t get
any residuals for it.
Someone just brought me --
bought me a big copperplate
that said "Bruges" on it,
so this is a movie
I talk about all the time.
-That´s got to be heavy.
-It is heavy, yeah.
Did you --
So that movie, I guess,
came out in 2007, yes?
-Yeah.
-And Colin Farrell,
Brenden Gleeson.
Do you look back
on that film fondly?
-Oh, very much.
My first feature film,
and, like, I didn´t know
what the hell I was doing,
but Colin and Brenden kind of
guided me through it,
and it was --
We were in Bruges,
which is, as you know,
one of the most beautiful
and boring towns
in all of Europe.
-Well, that --
It is interesting because
it is a balance of beauty
and not being very big.
-Yeah.
-You spent a lot of time there
because of the film.
-I went there, like,
maybe a couple years
before I wrote the script,
and it all just popped
into my head instantly,
pretty much,
and I was kind of really worried
that someone else would make
a film in Bruges
before I got to,
and steal my thunder.
-That´s really funny because
not only did they not,
but no one has made one since.
[ Laughter ]
-And funnily enough,
no one ever went to see
the movie, either so --
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it´s interesting,
because I went to Bruges.
After the film,
my wife and I went to Bruges.
And they -- the taxi driver
immediately clocked me
as an American tourist
who came because of the film.
So there is like a film
"In Bruges" tourism in Bruges.
-Oh, really?
-Do you feel like the Bruges --
the people of Bruges are happy
that you made the film?
Do they like it?
-I´ve never really been back
to check.
-Yeah.
-But I think the mayor --
No, I think the mayor
didn´t like it, so maybe --
-Oh, really?
I can´t believe they´re --
´Cause see, I want to do an
"In Bruges" reunion episode.
-I heard this.
-Yeah.
-I´d like to --
-You would do it?
-If you want your
viewing figures to really dip,
that would be the perfect - -
-No, I think that NBC
will be really excited
about "In Bruges" week.
[ Laughter ]
But so, this film, you know,
again, because I feel like
you are such a great writer
for actors,
and this film,
Frances McDormand,
who we saw in the clip --
absolutely fantastic.
Did you write this character
with her in mind?
-Yeah, this is completely
for Frances, like,
she´s one of
the best actors around,
and I´d always wanted
to work with her
for years and years.
We met after a play in New York
about almost 20 years ago.
-Oh, wow.
-And then we met again,
like, seven or eight years ago,
and she said,
"Write a part for me."
-Oh, wow.
-And you always obey
when Frances tells you
to do something, so that´s where
this film came about.
-And she is
a very unique character,
a very unique look
from the clip,
sort of the coveralls and the --
you know, the stuff in her hair.
Is that a look that you had
in mind from the beginning?
Do you guys work
on that together?
-Well, that was pretty much
Frances´ idea.
She plays a character who´s kind
of going to war with the town
and with the police.
So she wanted a uniform
that she wouldn´t have to
think about every day.
She wasn´t going to coordinate,
like, a blouse with a dress.
So she´s got this kind of
mechanics uniform,
and a bandana,
but we wanted a hairstyle
that would kind of match.
And at one point,
we were thinking of getting,
like, a skinhead.
-Uh-huh.
-And we did a kind of
computerized composite
of Frances with a skinhead
crew cut kind of thing,
and it didn´t quite -- yeah.
-No, yeah.
-We would have had
even less viewers
for this movie as "Bruges."
-Sub-Bruges?
You think you would
have gone sub-Bruges?
-Yeah, if that´s possible.
But -- And, yeah,
but she did have,
like, a little --
if you see the film,
she´s kind of got it shaved
in the back,
but the rest is swept up.
So it´s a pretty cool
iconic look she´s got going.